[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily a former ohio cop
now charged with a murder for the
shooting of an unarmed black man
the grand jury here found the truth
andre hill should not be dead
prosecutors seek a new arrest warrant
for the accused kenosha shooter
why attorneys for kyle rainhouse say
he's hiding out in a safe house
i have my phone and called the player
plus does oj simpson still owe millions
for the wrongful death lawsuit
in the murders of his former wife and
her boyfriend and
what investigators now know about the
shooter accused of killing two fbi
agents in florida
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a grand jury in ohio indicts a former
columbus police officer for murder
after he shot an unarmed black man long
crimes angenette levy is here
with details about the charges yeah
brian the city of columbus actually
fired adam coye
saying that his actions were not
justified now the grand jury
and the ohio attorney general say his
actions were actually criminal
former columbus police officer adam coy
didn't have his body worn camera
activated
when he first arrived at a home andre
hill was visiting in december
but a camera feature allows the minute
before activation to be recorded
so it captured him shooting andre hill
as he held up a cell phone
roll to your stomach now that was
moments after koi's shot hill
roll over dude columbus police fired coy
and a grand jury indicted him on charges
of murder
he's also charged with felonious assault
and two counts of dereliction of duty
truth is the best friend of justice
and the grand jury here found the truth
andre hill should not be dead attorney
general dave yost's office
is acting as special prosecutor yost
says the dereliction of duty charges
relate to koi not having his body worn
camera activated
and for not telling his fellow officers
he believed hill
posed a danger the vast virtue of law
enforcement is diminished
by the very few bad actors among its
ranks
and only by holding a bad actor
accountable
can that virtue be sustained
here's what i mean in plain english same
rules for everybody
now koi's lawyers say there was actually
a two to three minute
long interaction between coy and andre
hill in which he told him to come out of
the garage and he wouldn't do it
so they say you don't see that because
the body camera was simply not on
they say that coy feared for his life
because he believed that andre hill had
a gun
they cite u.s supreme court guidelines
and saying that the shooting was
justified
mr hill was not compliant with some
verbal orders that my client gave
and then um my client ordered him to
show his hands and come out
um and then when he came near the car mr
hill came near the car
his right hand was down low my client
couldn't see it his left hand was up
high
with a cell phone in it so as soon as
the mr hill came
across outside of the bumper of the car
my client
saw a round silver object in mr hill's
hand and he honestly believed that that
was a silver revolver
that's when he announced gun gun gun
step back and in protocol
and shot you have to view it through the
eyes of a reasonable police officer
that is the objective standard um that
granby connor dictates but
the subjective standard is that the
officer must be in fear
um for his life and yes that's what
we're saying that adam koi was in fact
in fear for his life that when he saw
mr hill's uh left hand come up with the
phone
um he was focused on his right hand and
at the time when his right hand came
up he believed that it was a revolver
and because of that
that's when he made that split second
decision to to shoot
and attorney mark collins said that the
object that coy actually saw in hill's
hand was a set of keys
now andre hill was just 47 years old
the lawyer for his family says an
indictment alone will not satisfy hill's
family
they are believed that the grand jury
franklin county citizens
returned an indictment for murder
for bologna this is something that
attorney wright would talk about
in a little more detail and failure
to render medical assistance they are
relieved for all these reasons
but the reason they are not satisfied
is because we know based on what has
happened before
in america that when a white police
officer
kills another black person
that does not guarantee a conviction
and they want alpha adam
now in ohio a murder charge carries a
mandatory sentence of 15 years to life
in prison
coy's attorneys say they will ask for a
reasonable bond when he
enters a not guilty plea on friday brian
thanks anjanet joining us today is new
york city public defender marvel brown
and terry austin marva reactions to the
indictment of former officer adam coy
and do you see a conviction in his
future
thank you brian i think that the defense
attorneys are saying all the right
things
justified use of force he believed
uh mr hill had a weapon and he felt like
his life was
threatened that's what the defense
attorney has to say
however thinking about the call that was
made
that brought the police to this location
it was
a noise disturbance not any allegation
of any violent crime
why did the officer come with his gun
drawn
there was another officer on the scene
who fired zero shots
she did not fear for her safety she did
not believe mr hill had a weapon
so when we have a trial in this case
and the jury looks at the video and sees
the fastness
in which mr hill was shot i believe
there will be a conviction terry same
question and do you agree or disagree
with anything marvis said
oh i agree 100 with what marvis said i
am
really grateful that there was an
indictment in this case
and i do see a conviction or at least i
hope that there might be a conviction
listen the shooting took place seconds
after
he responded and this as marvin said was
a 3-1-1
non-emergency call so it's another
traffic
case and you know he didn't turn on his
body camera
the only good thing that came out of all
this is now we have a new law
in columbus that says one you have to
turn on
your body camera and you have to render
first aid which i can't believe they
didn't do in this case
exactly now anjanet what is some of the
evidence the state has
aside from the body cam video yeah that
body camera video is obviously a big
piece of the evidence in this case but
the attorney general also cited
statements made by adam coy he was not
only
interviewed by vci agents in ohio for
two hours or so he also gave a written
statement
and the attorney general also mentioned
cyber data
and that's a big thing with the ohio
attorney general's office they do a lot
of these cyber
data cases where they do a deep dive
into people's cell phones and
facebook messages things like that so
that will all come into play as well
yeah i can see that coming into court
thank you all for contributing
still ahead on law and crime daily
should o.j simpson be forced to pay up
millions of dollars in a civil judgment
but first the video of the accused
kenosha shooter just after two people
were killed
what kyle rainhouse told police next
prosecutors in wisconsin are seeking a
new arrest warrant for the accused
kenosha shooter
saying he's violated bond conditions
because he didn't report his new address
kylo ren house was charged with shooting
three people killing two of them during
protests last summer
he's out on two million dollar bail
records show officials went to deliver a
court notice to his house
but learned he had moved months ago
prosecutors say he's supposed to notify
the court within 48 hours of moving
his defense is firing back telling a
judge rin house moved to a secret
location because of death threats
against him
newly released video shows detectives
reading written house his miranda rights
after the shooting because he like i
said he's a police explorer and you know
okay so you've probably heard something
like this before is it miranda yep
i have to read though because again i'm
in their house i don't know what they've
told you
in terms of you know obviously you're in
the handcuffs
i know okay do you want to have a lawyer
and sister well yes or no
i would like a lawyer but i'm willing to
talk and tell
a lawyer is available
they can't do anything because they
can't do anything until the lawyer comes
actually i don't want a lawyer right now
you can't you can't
listen listen you have to look at your
help yeah can i call my lawyer
once you've asked for a letter we don't
interview so we're yeah
police left the interrogation room but
cameras were still recording
capturing the defendant talking to his
mother about what people were saying
about them
on social media
the officers came back into the room to
tell written how he was going to be
arrested
that's when reign house made an unusual
request to officers asking them
to delete his social media accounts do
you believe there's probable cause for a
crime
doesn't mean the da's office is going to
see it that way so that's what you're
being honest
with the fucking point i'm i'm
okay i can't talk to you about it okay
i'm not here to interview you anymore
because you've asked for an attorney i
can't talk to you about the case
okay i'm just telling you what's going
to happen what is he looking at
uh it could range anywhere from uh
reckless injury to reckless homicide to
second-degree homicide i don't know yet
it's all going to depend on murder
that's what homicide is correct correct
delete my social media accounts like
after you guys
get your warrant to go through all my
and you make sure everything
like my social media is deleted i mean
we can't
here to discuss the ongoing kenosha
shooting case is public defender marvel
brown and co-host terry austin
marva there's a warrant out for
rittenhouse's arrest but it's based on
something
pretty minor and the defense has an
excuse for it how do you think the judge
should rule
on this issue when rittenhouse returns
back to court
the kenosha district attorney has an
interest in prosecuting this case
to the fullest extent of the law and
that includes
asking for the warrant asking for
increased bail however
rittenhouse appeared in court when he
was supposed to
even if the letter that was sent to his
home did not make it to him
he made it to court bail is about
ensuring the defendant's return to court
i think the judge is going to be more
upset with the defense attorney
than with written house because the
defense attorney had an obligation to
notify the court of the danger to the
client and request that his address be
held under seal
they did not make that request to the
court and it's not the defendant's fault
so maybe the defense attorney gets
chewed out but rin house gets to stay
out free i can see that happening
terry interrogations for the videos for
the defense can be really bad
but when you have a parent that are
speaking with your clients ugh
it gets it gets even worse how damning
do you think this video is for the
defense
or do you think it helps greenhouse in a
potential trial
you know brian i think it actually helps
him in a potential trial look whenever
you have a mother it underscores the
fact that this
is a child and i think a jury looking at
the fact
that she's crying hysterically it will
garner sympathy in fact i'd put all
mothers on the jury because they will be
sympathetic to this
and even when he says mom please stop
talking i think any parent
can understand that a teenager and i
quote teenager he's young
will say something like that yep i could
definitely see of course he was 17 at
the time he is now
18 so still a teenager i think something
that most mothers i have two mothers
here
so i think you guys probably know more
of how that operates thank you both
coming up on law on crime daily the
accused killer who apparently live
streamed the bodies
of his victims on social media plus an
exclusive
preview into a new series breaking down
the most chilling crimes
from investigations to the verdict the
trial of an ohio cheerleader
accused of murdering her baby after the
break
the trial of a cheerleader accused of
murdering her baby captivated many on
the long crime network
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross gives us an inside look into how
the case unfolded
on the new a e series killer cases
rhonda schwartz and i are executive
producing the show and this case was so
fascinating because
police were told after they discovered
the body buried in her backyard
where she had secretly a dug a grave
that according to the medical examiner
the bones appear to have been burned so
they get her
in a confession to admit she set fire to
the baby
only later does the medical examiner say
i was wrong
the bones were not burned so essentially
you have a false confession
which we see play out in the show the
prosecution went ahead with the case
anyway
still stuck to the murder charges even
though they were able to show pretty
clearly i think and you'll see in the
case that
it would be impossible to burn a baby
ladies and gentlemen we are here today
because the defendant
brooke richardson murdered a baby that
she didn't want
and never intended to keep she's a great
student she started doing competitive
cheer outside of the school skyler has
just learned she's pregnant
and she tells no one nobody knows about
this
sometime when her mother father and
brother were asleep
skylar delivers a baby girl she names
her daughter annabelle and then she
buries the remains
in the backyard he did give birth
to a newborn infant he caused the death
of that
infant she subsequently burned the
infant
they were on a one-way track to get her
to confess so they could take her to
jail
[Music]
people were ready to convict there was
false information
everywhere it was ugly
she was determined to keep her secret
i actually do an autopsy on the baby and
they find out that
[Music]
and i grabbed the gun trying to find the
first place to put a body no sir
the only thing they could do was kill it
you want to say anything
we the jury and you find the defendant
killer cases airs at 10 pm eastern on
thursdays on the a e networks
when we come back the deadly shootout in
south florida
two fbi agents dead three more wounded
what we now know about the alleged
shooter
and how the feds say he was waiting for
their arrival next
and now to check in on some of today's
top legal stories making headlines
terry austin has the latest on a civil
matter involving o.j simpson
o.j simpson reportedly still owes the
family of murder victim ron goldman
tens of millions of dollars his family
is asking a judge to make the juice
pay up according to court documents o.j
simpson was ordered to pay
33 million dollars after being found
liable for the deaths of goldman and
simpson's ex-wife
nicole brown simpson in 1994
but tmz's reporting that the former nfl
player
has only paid thousand dollars
the amount simpson now owes has
apparently more than
doubled due to interest simpson was
acquitted of double homicide but a civil
jury found him liable
for the two deaths a former
gubernatorial candidate has pled not
guilty to killing a 12-year-old girl
nearly 36 years ago a colorado grand
jury indicted stephen panke
for murder and kidnapping greenlee
police say the body of janelle matthews
was found in 2019 by construction
workers putting in a pipeline
according to investigators pankey was a
youth pastor at the victim's church
in 1984. they say he knew intimate
details about the killing
and made odd statements about the case
over the years an examination of her
remains reportedly revealed
she died from a gunshot wound to the
head
a california man was arrested after
police say he killed two people and then
live streamed their bodies on social
media
raymond weber is facing two counts of
murder and one count of felon in
possession of a firearm
investigators in vacaville said the
bodies of a 15-year-old girl
and 27-year-old woman were seen on the
floor of an apartment in the video
a judge ordered weber to be held in jail
without bond
prosecutors are expected to reach plea
deals with a new hampshire couple
charged in a murder decapitation police
say the wife told authorities her
husband shot and killed her lover
and then ordered her to chop off the
dead man's head and bury it separately
from his body
armando baron is charged with capital
murder and with assault for allegedly
beating his wife
during the ordeal bernie baron is
charged with falsifying evidence
the body of the victim 25-year-old
jonathan ameralt was left alone for four
days
the fbi has identified the now deceased
suspect believed to be behind the
killing of two agents and wounding of
three more
investigators say 55-year-old david lee
huber opened fire on asians serving a
search warrant
looking for evidence in a child
pornography case he reportedly monitored
the agent approaching his apartment
using a doorbell camera
records show hubert had a computer
consulting business and the agents were
planning on seizing his computer
as part of their investigation he's
accused of barricading himself in his
apartment
then turning the gun on himself special
agents laura swashenburger and daniel
aflin died of their injuries
the fbi director is hailing the agents
as heroes
back to break down the deadly search
warrant is marver brown and terry austin
marva the officers were there to stop
child pornography so what happens
to huber's computers and then child
pornography on it could that evidence
lead to saving children's lives or
prosecuting others for these crimes
definitely brian
the important thing is they the agents
went to the home with a valid search
warrant
they showed a judge that they had
probable cause and a judge signed off on
that warrant
so anything that's in that home that is
the subject of the search warrant
can be used in the prosecution of other
people that are connected to
mr huber's crimes right they can
get ip addresses email addresses for
anyone else that were connected to the
child pornography cases
and you can believe the government is
not going to let those officers death
be in vain they are heroes they are
respected they gave back to their
community they taught kids how to be
safe on the internet their deaths will
not be in vain
absolutely now terry we've covered a lot
of search warrants but
this was the deadliest day in fbi
history since 2008.
what are your thoughts on the officers
who died trying to arrest a man accused
of child pornography
well marvin's exactly right these are
heroes i mean we know that agent
schwarzenberger
was only 43 she had two children the
other agent was only 36
and they were highly regarded and in
fact we know
already that director christopher wray
has visited at least one of the families
and intends to visit the other so
they will be you know remembered forever
as they should thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you